an environmental catastrophe is in the
making but the crisis could soon be
averted organized by the UN paid for by
private donors and even a crowdfunding
campaign the 129 million dollars raised
going towards the cost of two salvage
companies overseen by houthi supervisors
and I think this combination has worked
very well for us to find a way forward
for a problem that's been here for eight
years people have been talking about it
but not doing anything about it this
group has been able to do something
about it I believe will be successful
we'll continue to push forward until we
succeed
U.N officials have warned that the fso
suffered could spill four times as much
oil as the 1989 Exxon Valdez disaster of
Alaska it was initially constructed as a
super tanker but was later converted
into floating storage for oil it's been
sitting near the yemeni ports of hadada
since 1988. the country's Civil War
forced maintenance to be suspended in
2015 but progress has come quickly
during the past year we held several
meetings and discussions with United
Nations there was progress and delays at
times but thanks to Allah we have
reached this today which is the
culmination of work in the past period
the arrival of the vessel to carry out
the operation is the first practical
operational step
more than one million barrels of crude
oil is still sitting on board the tanker
as it decays in the red sea it's now
said to be transferred to another tanker
which set sail from China in early April
raising hopes that the worst oil spill
in recent memory can be avoided Alex
beard Al Jazeera